have you ever had a 100 accuracy game if
you have a great job if you haven't
hopefully it's on the way for you but
today we have five perfect 100 accuracy
games let's check this first one this
one is actually Narayan Naval good
versus International Master Zuber which
with three R's this was in the title
Tuesday let's see what happened in fact
E4 E5 and the Knight F3 and
F5
okay well uh here this is uh don't try
this at home of course but you can it
just may not work in your favor and a
lot of times there's lots of Tricks here
lots of fun and tricks this is why
people play this opening this is tricky
it's fun it's like tactics and weird
stuff that happens but the F5 move so F5
this is uh called the lot being Gambit
but white plays is 100 accurately by
playing Knight C3 just defending the
pawn right we can also take on E5 in
many cases if F takes E4 black is like
hey you know what whatever let's just go
Knight to C6 defend you didn't fall for
my tricks whites like absolutely not I'm
gonna play D4 strike in the center
stuff's getting very strange and open
and you've already opened you know your
F Pawn here you can get in trouble very
very fast so okay cool after the D4 move
F takes E4 now in this position you know
they're Knights hanging right and also
this Pawn's hanging so the best move
here would be now you take C5 right
still 100 accuracy if Knight takes E5 we
have our own stuff like you know Pawn
takes we have some Queen H5 action
Knight takes E4 is also as a thing as
well this diagonal is super open right
because we pushed the app Pawn so Knight
F6 stopping a queen H5 and then white
plays Bishop C4 says oh you're not going
to Castle number one I'm also threading
F7 so black makes a logical move here
and plays V5 now it's white to move of
course 100 accuracy every move was right
here for white what is that move in fact
white to move what do you do in this
position
the move here is in fact even Nakamura
actually missed this trick as well is
1965 you're playing like an engine now
that is correct Knight takes D5 that's a
big move from a big fellow what happens
okay well if Knight takes D5 which
happened in the game Queen H5 check with
G6 oh yeah we're gonna win the Rook
right you're familiar with this tactic
if not do more puzzles do more tactics
every day right so after G6 Knight takes
G6 and we're expecting a pawn takes G6
right so we can just take the Rook we
can also probably just take on here and
play Bishop G5 next I mean you hate
you're for choice you can do whatever
you like in fact after Knight takes G6
Black Goes Knight F6
thinking they're being clever oh I'm
being very clever here you move your
queen away I'm gonna move my rook and
I'm gonna be fine right after you move
the queen maybe I could go this is so
bad like you can even take there this is
just very problematic for the black
pieces for sure I mean it already
started with the opening but after
Knight F6 hitting the queen okay what do
we play in this position is right to
move 100 accuracy what do you play
the move here is an attraction tactic
Bishop F7 that's a big move there pretty
nice
extra nice 100 percent nice of course
after Bishop F7 very nice of King to D7
we have Queen F5 King to D6 and then
Bishop F4 is going to Checkmate right
let's actually just show that here and
then uh Queen D5 King D6 Bishop F4 and
mates okay well mating after 95. it's
gonna mean it made soon made soon in
fact you're busy before it's not me but
it's definitely going to make it so I
mean obviously your king is on D6 okay
all right cool that's not gonna be good
at all anyway shape and or form so after
Bishop F7 check there's King takes F7
and then knight uh 95 which is checking
very nice you also could have taken the
Rook but this is even better 95 uh King
E6 Queen F7 King D6 and the finale move
is what that's for you to figure out
right now what does white play in this
position
here it is you're correct it is night to
C4 and you move no more that is
Checkmate get him off the board great
job there guys that was cool this was a
hundred percent game this was number
five let's move to number four okay guys
here's our next 100 accuracy game with
the white pieces we have a man named
Magnus Carlson I wonder if we've heard
of that guy before versus a d-pan chakra
barfi right this was back in 2004
actually so let's check this game I was
100 accuracy game E4 C5 we got a
sicilian on the board Knight C3 it's a
little bit different mixing up some move
orders people just sometimes don't know
what to do here and it is kind of
annoying when you see you know the
Knight C3 from a sicilian player side
you're like I don't know what you're
gonna play next right the main move is
actually E5 but Knight F6 was chosen
here and then Bishop to B5 right so
pretty pretty nice uh very not very very
like rosalimo like it's weird it's very
strange you know for the Sicilian
players chapter Bishop B5 there's E5 now
E5 here is is not the most accurate way
it should be with the Knight back chili
back on G8 here but okay it is playable
Bishop takes C6 first so taking the the
Knight D takes C6 and then Knight takes
C5 I'll take the ball and you're gonna
give me the pawn and then black plays a
nice little Knight takes E4 right he's
like oh I'm gonna get that right back
he's like what do you mean I'm gonna get
that right back right he just stole a
piece or he stole a pawn here we got a
piece
of course actually after Knight takes C5
Knight takes C4 right it looks kind of
strange we took a piece he took a pawn
but then Queen D4 is the idea we
actually get it right back now we're
gonna move through some some moves um
quicker here because we have more games
to look at and this is a longer game so
after Queen D4 White Castle pretty easy
get to get the king out of the center
Queen takes E5 you already feel like
white has an advantage or something
because of just Rook E1 you feel that
you can actually do some things here and
be quite annoying Rick's E1 which puts
pressure on this whole file here but
the move here was actually D4
that's right there is a sick move d4 wow
I mean it's very interesting to say the
least right this is a dynamic of peace
or dynamic move um which is very strong
it's also very tricky if Queen takes D4
we're playing for initiative here we
just want to open up the game we play
Queen F3 then something like Rook to E1
right you can also Play Bishop E3 at the
right moment we play C3 all kind of
stuff it's just playing for initiative
here after the D4 move it's Dynamic so C
takes D4 was actually the move in the
game after C takes D4
right we go rookie one an idea here of
course is you obviously can't take the
Knight you know even back here D4 Queen
takes E4 rookie one so you know C takes
D4 Rook to E1 is now played and then
Bishop to E6 question mark move you just
move the queen right you actually had to
move the queen like somewhere strange
which is actually I mean it's kind of
hard to see you're gonna play Bishop B7
and kingy d8 Bishop E6 is a move but
it's just not not that not that good of
a move to be honest after Bishop B6 the
move here for white is what what does
white do here to get an advantage you
need an advantage here and this one's
not that easy to find what is the move
the move here for white actually is
nothing super spectacular just a
development move Bishop to G5 right is
you have development problems you want
to put the bishop where right maybe on
E7 so now if you put the bishop on E7
you're not gonna cast so F6 is going to
come on this is really ridiculous right
Knight takes F6 even as the first move
we can play we're also threatening
things like Knight F6 myself so Bishop
B7 right Bishop B7 was play here now you
can go Knight F6 which is a thing I mean
you also black has some compensation
right after Knight F6 I mean Bishop
takes Rook takes E5 Bishop takes like
this isn't that clear-cut even the
engine thinks that it's quite equal
right now even though you do have the
queen
um over you know Queen Rick and Bishop
and two Bishops versus two Rooks like
black is okay black is very playable
here but okay after the bishop B7 move
we have F4 from White which hits the
queen pretty strong we want to be
initiative move fast do things with time
uh so we can save time Queen D5 and then
we want to keep the king in the center
and we also want to play on initial of
speed development time so the move here
is Bishop B7 doesn't give him time to
take or Castle King takes E7 right now
we want to think initiative again
forward moving forward white to move
what do you do in this position what did
Magnus Carlson play
foreign
very strong if Bishop takes F5 we have
Knight C3 check winning the queen and if
Queen takes F5 which is actually the
game we'll be supposed to do that well
then we can take on D4 your King's in
the center pieces are level right we
have the same amount of material besides
a pawn I mean white is down a pawn but
you don't even feel that like you don't
even feel that because of the fact that
like G7 is hanging kings in the center
dark squares are extremely weak Queen B4
is coming this is very very very
annoying and hard to play from the black
side now of course we still have lots of
moves here so let's go through it Queen
D5 Queen B4 check C5 happen because if
you move the king there's Knight D6 is
there's also a rook a to d ones right
we're getting so problems Knight takes
C5 A5 happens he wants to hit the queen
queen obviously moves back to A3 so we
can keep the diagonal onto the king
queen D4 check gotta step out the way
Queen B3 we want to trade Queens
Magnus says no Queen E3
and there's no more game and this was
100 accuracy this is 20 moves yikes
that's very strong and this was in 2004
Magnus wow that's amazing but this was
another one of those 100 games now let's
look at another one here we are with our
next 100 accuracy game and this one goes
way back 1892. we have seabert Terrace
versus York Marco okay perfect let's see
what it was it was E4 and then E5 93 and
Knight C6 Bishop B5 for Roy or Roy Lopez
right played all the way even back then
now after Bishop B5 D6 was the move here
usually A6 is the more common move uh
nowadays is A6 you can also play Knight
F6 you can play D6 you can play anything
but back then of course D6 was just a
little bit more common after the D6 move
we have D4 right which is nice striking
in the center this is a cool way to play
right this is why with the A6 um option
Bishop A4 you have an additional B5 but
here you don't have it so D4 is we're
trying to take advantage of that right
Bishop to D7 and then Knight to C three
so we're just developing our pieces
Knight F6 happens after the Knight F6
move castles very common stuff after
Bishop B7 we have um The Rook E1 move
now this rookie one move actually is uh
there's like a little bit dubious and
there's a dubious sign here of course
because uh usually you can take there's
actually Wesley so Nakamura game it
should take C6 right is a thing and then
you can actually play Queen to D3 and
Bishop E3 just having a slight pull on a
slight Edge for white
um there but rookie one it does make
sense though it defends the pawn defends
the pawn it's also a natural move to
make you can always play Bishop F1 at
some point we're also threatening to try
to take on C6 and take on E5 without
worrying about E4 hanging let's see what
happens after Castle she's like oh wait
a second hold on like what is this move
like this is a mistake in fact this is a
well-known mistake and it is there's
traps in here but let's see what happens
after the castles move take that one
takes takes takes takes takes takes
takes
takes takes and then
now obviously if you do work takes E4
you can just resign before they play
Rook D1 because you are gonna get made
it right so we're like wait did we I
thought we won a pawn here so why did we
do this well a little subtlety here is
what this is on you 100 accuracy game
white to move what do you do
thank you
the move here actually is Knight to D3
very subtle move D3 not F3 because we
need to be able to use this Pawn believe
it or not after Knight D3 it hits the
Knight you move the Knight to the wrong
Square you're or anywhere really for
that matter you're going to lose some
material you move the bishop we take the
Knight so you're in the in a dilemma you
need to do something now so F5 right
defends the Knight it's the only way to
really defend the Knight besides a rook
D4 but that could be hit with another
Tempo that's something you don't want so
F3 hits the Knight like wait a second F3
can't be right right
it like can't be right because I have
Bishop C5 check only way to actually try
to you know defend my material here or
keep my material Bishop C5 hits the
check right of course we do want to uh
trade this because if we just move the
king tonight can't get away in some
cases right I mean King F1 is actually a
bishop B6 which is a quite strange here
and then Pawn takes Knight and then
takes and like there you give them some
initiative you also move the Knight and
they go G5 themselves so you have to be
actually very careful here so the move
here is just take it you thought you
were getting a piece but cool we didn't
get the piece but we're still going to
get some material remember this is 100
accuracy game like wow Terrace is very
strong after Knight takes C5 Bishop G5
very important detail it hits the Rook
but we're also hitting something else
because after you defend we were hitting
Bishop E7 oh you had to watch out for
that right that's why you went Rook V5
which defends the Knight makes total
sense okay so now I can you know move
this Rook away and not worry about
losing material or do I after rookie
eight this next move the game is over
the next school the game is over white
played a move there was no more PGN
right to move what is it
the move here is
C4
need more simple move here but this is a
nice trap through the Roy to something
of course played the game back to look
at it to see how you can get this in
your own games and by yourself as well
so C4 the idea here is absolutely
hitting the Rook you're gonna lose some
material whether it's through an
exchange or if they're a piece right so
Marco just threw in the towel there and
said this is over it's another 100
accuracy game that was cool let's see
the next one here we are with our next
100 accuracy game with the white pieces
we have hikaranakamura and with the
black pieces we have loic van Welly
right this was back in 2010. watch this
one okay E4 C5 Knight F3 D6 D4 take take
Knight F6 right we got okay now you do
it Friday night C3 I mean it could go
many ways classical still Dragon but
this one was a night or Sicilian the
trusty naidorf A6 and then we go with
the sharp line which is one of the
sharpest which is Bishop to G5 very very
sharp line you can definitely get into
trouble honestly for both sides it's
razor sharp open Sicilian razor sharp
Bishop G5 Knight B to D7 right this is
one of the flexible ways to play against
the bishop G5 variation you have many
ways I mean I'm a fan of the bishop C4
lines myself just quick development but
also uh you can play app four as well
there's many moves you can play Bishop
E2 like h3a3 whatever you want in a way
right it just depends on what you want
Hikaru chose F4 and then after Queen B6
sort of the poison Pawn type variations
here you can give this Pawn up or you
cannot he says I'm gonna give it up
Queen D2 now are you gonna take on B2
right because this is sort of a poison
Pawn like so he takes it and this one is
just a worse version of the poison bomb
you are not supposed to take this right
here engine gives Eco but this takes an
engine like defense especially against
an aggressive player like Hikaru after
Queen takes B2 Rook to B1 first off we
hit the queen remember this is 100
accuracy game watch the moves it takes
this is 100 accuracy the moves that were
played here oh my goodness after Rook to
be one there was Queen A3 first movie
play here is Bishop takes F6 right lots
of times we do want to deal with this
bishop you also give them ideas with
sometimes Knight takes E4 H6 and G5 you
get them you give them lots of play we
also want to put in one night on C5 so
we take okay Bishop takes F6 so you're
either gonna damage the structure or
this Knight can't come to C5 to attack
the center more with E4 and you just be
up a pawn and have some conversation so
Bishop takes F6 Knight takes F6 right
then we want to keep some initiative E5
take the Knight back away make sure you
move somewhere if you don't we have E6
in some cases the Knight can swing in
the D5 B5 sometimes there's lots of play
and it's gonna get very sharp here so
Pawn takes once Pawn takes back Knight
back to D7 and then we have a nice move
here let's see if you can find it it's
right to move here there's so many
possibilities and believe I mean it's
crazy that this is a hundred percent
accuracy here because you have a lot of
moves here and of course Hikaru found
the best one here let's see if you can
find the best move right to move what do
you do
foreign
number one on the engine played Knight
D5 it's a very simple move it moves
closer to the king to black skin it's
also in the center of the board these
ponies look very nice here and Knight to
C7 is a threat right so black is like
all right you know what hey you're
already attacking me I'm already like
why did I take that pawn on B2 why did
Bobby Fischer do the poison bomb
variation why did he do that Queen C5
okay Queen C5 hitting the Knight but
also defending C7 so everything seems
okay I can breathe a little bit but when
you have initiative and you're attacking
one thing to do is keep doing that
Knight to B3 hit the queen 100 accuracy
once again that was the right move best
move Queen goes to C6 next move here
Knight A5 look at just the Relentless
attacking pushing you back you got to do
things you gotta move Queen went to C5
after Queen C5 not really attacking the
ninth but maybe some B6 action I mean
there's all kind of things that can
happen but definitely white is in the
driver's seat he says you know what I'm
just gonna take the pawn cash in hit the
queen once again and it's a temple
Bishop takes B7 you're gonna allow to
The Rook to the seventh rank come on now
come on that's not gonna happen so he's
like yeah I'm already like this is a
problem let me just back up Queen to CC
let me just chill and relax you're doing
too much Hikaru and he does even more
here white to move what do you do in
this position
the move here guys believe it or not is
Rook B6
this game right here is ridiculous Rook
B6 and you see the games over you see
the little King there no more PGN no
more PG this is a resignation this is 17
moves guys of course the game was over
now why is it over after rugby six
obviously like bro what if I just take
the Rook what are you talking about oh
was that a mouse slip or over the board
slip what are you doing well of course
this is up to you to find out why can't
he take them
in fact he can take the Rook if you like
the Knight of six no matter how you
capture Queen sack Tangled Upon take
with this Pawn I will even let you take
with the Rook or the bishop it's illegal
but I'll let you do it you're gonna go
ahead Play I Don't Care I don't even
care right would it however you take it
there's made on d8 beautiful absolutely
stunning 100 accuracy from Hikaru here
nothing less very nice let's move to our
final one all right and here we are with
our last 100 accuracy game we had to go
all the way back take it way way way way
back in 1911 with uh the world champion
Alexander eliakin or alakai as we like
to say versus Oscar tenor 1911 white
pieces Alexander elyakit all right E4 E5
and well hey what was played back then
of course romantic style right of course
you can still play this today too as
well the good times F4
the good times at four the king's Gambit
right so Bishop C5 we have Knight F3 D6
and ic3 development very easy in fact
you actually see a transposition here
into what we call the Vienna uh after
Knight F6 Bishop C4 Knight C6 and D3 you
see this in the Vienna nowadays where if
there's many moves that of course white
can play in black and play two as well
many routes so black chose Bishop G4 the
more active route I'm pretty uh it's a
most played move actually back then too
as well but nowadays uh even for Russian
Carlson has been in this position before
so it's very active very active play
Knight A4 what we want to do here is
grab the bishop pair it's very important
to try to get off these Bishops because
one Bishop is stopping us from casting
and one is bearing down over here so it
can get very sharp very sharp he takes
F4 we definitely will take this capture
we like this capture we take the bishop
first and then we take the pawn right
now black plays Knight H5 to hit uh F4
we have to go back to E3 so we can play
Bishop F2 in many cases but also hit C5
so cool Bishop goes back to E3 to hit
the C5 Pawn after Knight E5 which is a
blunder immediately like wow how is this
a blunder I mean he's pending like I'm
hitting Knight takes D C4 this is this
is nice how is this a blunt double
question mark what okay how though it's
white to move what did Alexander Elia
can do in this position
the saying goes that if you can sack
your queen you do it don't do that don't
do that okay but you consider it after
with calculation right so Knight takes
E5 right we're threatening Queen takes
G4 he's like well I have to take the
queen so he takes the queen okay Bishop
F7 check was the whole idea right if we
have King f8 then Bishop takes C5 and we
get the queen right back with interest
we also could take the Knight we could
take you know the bishop here well we
should take the bishop though because
The Bishop's defending tonight we're
just showing you like whatever what's
going on here it should take C5 is a
strong move of King f8 very strong you
get the material back immediately after
King fa so okay King E7 you're like oh I
got this well dude yeah where do you go
next Chad right where do you go next
where do you go next white Timber where
you go
shout out to you if you said Bishop G
finally who doesn't
you need to do more tactics it's not
that's not the move calculate it's not
it Bishop G5 it's not we block with the
Knight and have a nice night it's not
gonna be a good night for you after
Bishop G5 check Knight to F6 didn't work
try again so we play it's the other way
Bishop takes C5 King cannot run the D6
we have to go King F6 but wait wait a
second can you have six the knights
hanging so I lost my queen
the knights hanging and I don't have a
clear mate yet or do you it's right to
move what do you do in this position
beautiful move here 100 accuracy castles
with Jack
when do you ever get that I guess it's
just rare that you ever get that right
now let's go King G5 King G5 didn't
happen but it leads to a pretty mate
after Bishop B3 King H4 Rook F5 that's
hard to find this didn't happen in the
game but we're just showing you what
happens Rick F5 G6 Bishop F2 check 93
and taking uh or also Bishop G3 leads to
mate as well this is a prettier one with
the pawn but man king hunt so okay we
know that's gonna be a thing but in the
game believe it or not it was King takes
E5 which leads to what finish this off
100 accuracy you get a piece of this
it's white to move what do you do
the move here is simple work F5 and we
live and it's made that was beautiful
100 accuracy all the way even back then
in 1911 right this was cool stuff 100
accuracy games five of them hopefully
you learned something from each of them
and of course if you like this video
then just wait after the video to watch
some more of videos just like this we'll
see you guys on the next one
[Music]